It's only getting every customer's order right. It's only a point-of-sale system connected by Spectrum fiber-powered business internet, helping you track hundreds of secure transactions. And it's all backed by 24-7 U.S.-based customer support and local technicians. It's only everything. Get business internet advantage free, forever, when you get four mobile lines from Spectrum. Visit Spectrum.com slash free for life to find out how. Restrictions apply. Service is not available in all areas.
这仅仅是确保每一位顾客的订单准确无误。这仅仅是一个通过 Spectrum 光纤商业互联网连接的销售终端系统，帮助你追踪数百笔安全交易。而且这一切都有全天候美国本土客户支持和当地技术人员作为后盾。这仅仅是一切。当你购买 Spectrum 的四条移动线路时，即可永久免费获得商业互联网优势。访问 Spectrum.com 斜杠 free for life 了解详情。受相关条款限制。并非所有地区均提供此服务。
We've all seen the headlines. The U.S. workforce is burned out. Every week seems to bring another survey. 69% of frontline health care workers say they feel burned out. 29% of all remote workers very often or always feel burned out at work. Teachers, tech workers, veterinarians, name the profession. There's probably a news story about how burnt out its practitioners are. Even young content creators on social media are, quote,
我们都看过这些头条新闻。美国劳动力已经精疲力竭。似乎每周都会出现一项新的调查。69% 的一线医护人员表示他们感到精疲力竭。29% 的远程办公人员非常频繁或总是感到工作倦怠。教师、科技工作者、兽医，随便说出一个职业，可能都会有一篇关于该行业从业者有多么倦怠的新闻报道。甚至社交媒体上的年轻内容创作者也，引用，
burned out and breaking down, unquote, according to a New York Times story published in June. The word burnout has become ubiquitous. It seems to sum up the stress and exhaustion and disaffection that many of us are feeling this year. But are workers more burned out than ever? And what does the term burnout actually mean? How does burnout differ from, say, fatigue or stress?
“精疲力竭，濒临崩溃”，引用结束，据《纽约时报》六月发表的一篇报道称。“倦怠”（burnout）这个词已经变得无处不在。它似乎总结了我们许多人在今年所感受到的压力、疲惫和不满。但员工是否比以往任何时候都更加倦怠？“倦怠”这个词到底是什么意思？倦怠与疲劳或压力有什么不同？
How do you know if you're burned out? And what can individuals, employers, and society do to combat workplace burnout? Welcome to speaking of psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Christina Maslach, a professor of Psychology Emerita at the University of California, Berkeley, and one of the world's foremost experts on occupational burnout.
你怎么知道自己是否倦怠了？个人、雇主和社会能做些什么来对抗职场倦怠？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是加州大学伯克利分校心理学名誉教授、全球职业倦怠领域最顶尖的专家之一克里斯蒂娜·马斯拉赫（Dr. Christina Maslach）博士。
In the early 1980s, she developed the Maslac burnout inventory, the standard tool used to measure job burnout. Her work helped lead the World Health Organization to rest. recognize burnout as an occupational phenomenon in its 11th edition of the International Classification of Diseases in 2019. Over the past year, she's also offered her thoughts to the news media as an expert on the COVID-19 pandemic, job burnout, and work life. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Maslock. Oh, thank you. It's just a delight to be here. Let's start by defining job burnout.
在 20 世纪 80 年代初，她开发了“马斯拉赫倦怠量表”（Maslach Burnout Inventory），这是衡量职业倦怠的标准工具。她的工作促使世界卫生组织在 2019 年发布的第 11 版《国际疾病分类》中，将倦怠认定为一种职业现象。在过去的一年里，她还作为新冠疫情、职业倦怠和工作生活方面的专家，向新闻媒体表达了自己的见解。感谢您今天加入我们的节目，马斯拉赫博士。哦，谢谢。能来到这里真是太高兴了。让我们从定义职业倦怠开始吧。
A lot of people seem to think it's synonymous with stress and exhaustion, but burnout has a much more precise definition than that. So what is the difference between burnout, stress, exhaustion, depression, and is it a medical diagnosis? First, to begin with, it is not a medical diagnosis. And the World Health Organization made that very clear. It said it is not a medical condition. It's an occupational phenomenon. So it is a stress response. Exhaustion is, in fact, part of the burnout response.
很多人似乎认为它与压力和疲惫是同义词，但倦怠的定义比这要精确得多。那么，倦怠、压力、疲惫、抑郁之间有什么区别？它是一种医学诊断吗？首先，它不是一种医学诊断。世界卫生组织对此说得很清楚。它表示这不是一种医疗状况，而是一种职业现象。所以它是一种压力反应。事实上，疲惫是倦怠反应的一部分。
But it goes beyond the stress of responding to pronic job stress. and involves two other components. One is an increasingly negative, cynical, hostile response to the job, to the work you're doing, take this job and shove it, which leads to people not doing the job well, doing the bare minimum rather than their very best. And it also includes a negative sense of self and how your professional efficacy. Maybe I'm not really good at this. Maybe I made a mistake going here. So it's those three components, the stress response of exhaustion, the negative response to the job of cynicism, and the negative response to self of inefficacy. And so it's not, it can be a step in the path towards other kinds of problems like depression or anxiety, but it is a mistake, I think. And the World Health Organization agrees on that point and says that, that it's not a medical diagnosis. So it's not something that should be treated in that way. And it is not identified within the DSM, for example, because it's a more human condition or response to stressors.
但它不仅仅是应对慢性工作压力的压力，还涉及另外两个组成部分。一个是对应对工作、所做的事情产生日益消极、愤世嫉俗、敌对的反应，即“这工作爱谁干谁干”，这导致人们无法做好工作，只做最低限度的工作，而不是尽其所能。它还包括一种消极的自我感和职业效能感。也许我真的不擅长这个。也许我选择这里是个错误。所以它包含这三个组成部分：作为压力反应的疲惫、作为对工作消极反应的愤世嫉俗，以及作为对自我消极反应的效能感缺失。所以它不是，它可能是通往抑郁或焦虑等其他问题路径上的一步，但我认为，将其视为医学诊断是错误的。世界卫生组织也同意这一点，并表示它不是一种医学诊断。因此，它不应该以那种方式进行治疗。例如，它没有被列入《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM），因为它是一种更具人性化的状况或对压力源的反应。
So is it, how is it different from just plain old stress and exhaustion? Well, exhaustion is part of burnout. So it's not different from that, but it includes more than just exhaustion. we will see people who have exhaustion because they have way too much to do and can't possibly meet all the demands and all of that kind of thing but they still like their job they're they feel good about what they're doing they still feel good about themselves and how well they're doing they're just really really tired and it's just hard to sort of keep up so that's what we call an overextended profile but it's not burnout where
那么，它与单纯的压力和疲惫有何不同？嗯，疲惫是倦怠的一部分。所以它与疲惫并不完全不同，但它包含的不仅仅是疲惫。我们会看到一些人因为事情太多、无法满足所有要求等原因而感到疲惫，但他们仍然喜欢自己的工作，他们对自己在做的事情感觉良好，对自己的表现也感觉良好，他们只是非常非常累，很难跟上节奏，这就是我们所说的“过度延伸型”状态，但这并不是倦怠，因为
which is a high frequency of all three things, exhaustion, cynicism, and a lack of professional efficacy on the job. How do you think the pandemic has affected burnout? There have been a lot of articles about the term burnout during the past year, but does that reflect reality? Are people more burned out than ever? It's a little hard to know exactly in terms of actual data and research data. It wasn't, I mean, people talk about it,
倦怠是这三者（疲惫、愤世嫉俗和职业效能感缺失）的高频出现。你认为疫情对倦怠产生了什么影响？过去一年里有很多关于“倦怠”一词的文章，但这反映了现实吗？人们是否比以往任何时候都更加倦怠？就实际数据和研究数据而言，很难确切知道。并不是说，人们谈论它，
analyze it, complain about it, but we don't have evidence, basis of evidence beyond this sort of self-report there. For some people and some occupations, yes, I think healthcare, which you mentioned earlier, is one good example. Teachers and schools might be another one where the pandemic really changed their job and the conditions under which they were working. And so that That really just made it much more difficult for them to do their job well. The demands, you know, the workload went up. The exhaustion was going up. But we were also seeing problems, you know, with the rest of the sort of burnout response.
分析它，抱怨它，但除了这种自我报告之外，我们没有证据基础。对于某些人和某些职业，是的，我认为你之前提到的医疗保健就是一个很好的例子。教师和学校可能是另一个例子，疫情确实改变了他们的工作和工作条件。因此，这确实使他们更难做好工作。要求，你知道，工作量增加了。疲惫感在增加。但我们也看到了其他倦怠反应方面的问题。
So there are some places where, yes, I think that's true. But to the extent that burnout sometimes gets overused to mean all kinds of things beyond a stress response to job stressors, there could be other things that were happening in people's lives that would lead them to be experiencing stress. And so for some professions, I would say, yes, that was the case. But in other cases, I don't think that was happening necessarily. Well, putting aside the pandemic, what are the risk factors for job burnout? To go back to the World Health Organization statement, it's a response to chronic job stressors that have not been successfully managed. And so what you're talking about, we're talking about here is a high frequency of these stressors. It's not something that people experience
所以有些地方，是的，我认为这是事实。但如果倦怠有时被过度使用，用来指代压力反应之外的各种事情，那么人们生活中可能还发生了其他导致他们感到压力的事情。所以对于某些职业，我会说是的，情况确实如此。但在其他情况下，我不认为必然如此。好吧，撇开疫情不谈，职业倦怠的风险因素是什么？回到世界卫生组织的声明，它是对未得到成功管理的慢性工作压力源的反应。所以我们在这里谈论的是这些压力源的高频率。这不是人们经历的
occasionally or only a couple times a year. They're facing it daily, you know, they're facing it on a regular high frequency. And so the chronic nature of the job stressors is really what's critical here. The successfully managed can be done by the individual can be, but often really is done by the unit, the team, the work group, the organization, the occupation, World Health didn't designate it as being managed by just the individual. And what the research data really supports is the notion that it's really the relationship between people and their job, whether there's a good match or fit or a mismatch that really is problematic and raises the risk of burnout. And so what we have found in the research is that there are at least six major areas in which a mismatch
偶尔或一年几次的事情。他们每天都在面对，你知道，他们是在高频率地面对。因此，工作压力源的慢性性质在这里至关重要。所谓的“成功管理”可以由个人完成，但通常确实是由单位、团队、工作组、组织、职业来完成的，世界卫生组织并没有将其指定为仅由个人管理。研究数据真正支持的观点是，这实际上是人与工作之间的关系，即是否存在良好的匹配或契合，还是不匹配，这才是真正有问题并增加倦怠风险的原因。因此，我们在研究中发现，至少有六个主要领域存在不匹配，
between the job and the person, you know, the work and the worker, are critical. So the one everyone thinks about, of course, is workload, where the mismatch is high demands, low resources, lots to do, but not enough time or people or tools or information to get it done. But there are five others, and sometimes those are more important even than workload. There's control how much choice, discretion, say you have over what you do to innovate or do a little better or differently. Or are you don't have the control over the work that you're doing. And that's a huge one. A third area is a mismatch in terms of reward.
即工作与人（工作与工作者）之间的不匹配是至关重要的。每个人都会想到的当然是工作量，即高要求、低资源的不匹配，事情很多，但没有足够的时间、人员、工具或信息来完成。但还有其他五个领域，有时它们比工作量更重要。一个是控制权，即你在工作中有多少选择权、裁量权、发言权，去创新或做得更好或有所不同。或者你对正在做的工作没有控制权。这是一个巨大的因素。第三个领域是奖励方面的不匹配。
And it turns out not so much pay and perks per se, but recognition for having done. something well and you know getting those kinds of social and intrinsic rewards of doing a good job fourth area is what we call community and this is the workplace community who are the people that you are in regular contact and interaction with your colleagues your boss people you supervise the customers or your clients or you know patients depends what it is and And are those relationships in that workplace community supportive and figuring out how to work out problems and do things better? Or is it a really toxic environment where you feel that you're going to be bullied or, you know, treated badly or kept out of things and all of this kind of thing?
事实证明，这不仅仅是薪水和福利本身，而是对做得好的事情的认可，你知道，获得那种做好工作带来的社会和内在奖励。第四个领域是我们所说的社区，这是职场社区，即你经常接触和互动的人，你的同事、老板、你监督的人、顾客或客户，或者你知道，病人，取决于具体情况。职场社区中的这些关系是否具有支持性，是否能共同解决问题并把事情做得更好？还是一个非常恶劣的环境，让你觉得会被欺负，或者，你知道，被虐待或被排挤，所有这些事情？
So people talk about it as a socially toxic workplace in that case. Fifth area has to do with fairness, sort of basic human need to be treated fairly in whatever the system is, whatever the problems are. Being treated unfairly, being, this is where we talk about glass ceilings or discrimination, or people getting a head by lying and cheating rather than actually deserving of something. So being treated unfairly really keeps you out of the workplace community and makes you feel really disreservation. expected and that can lead to a lot of the cynicism that we see with burnout. And finally, the sixth area has to do with values and the meaning of the work and the pride you take in doing it well and contributing something and that you're not in an environment of value conflicts or unethical behavior or you're being asked to do things that are, you know,
所以人们在这种情况下称之为“社会性恶劣职场”。第五个领域与公平有关，这是一种基本的人类需求，即在任何制度下、任何问题中都受到公平对待。受到不公平对待，被，这就是我们谈论的“玻璃天花板”或歧视，或者人们通过撒谎和作弊而不是真正应得而获得成功。因此，受到不公平对待确实会让你被职场社区排斥，让你感到非常不被尊重，这会导致我们在倦怠中看到的许多愤世嫉俗。最后，第六个领域与价值观、工作的意义以及你因做好工作并做出贡献而产生的自豪感有关，而且你所处的环境不存在价值观冲突、不道德行为，或者你被要求做一些，你知道，
you just feel are not right or wrong in some way. And so it's those six areas, workload control, reward, community, fairness, and values that are the kind of six drivers at this point that we know of that pose risks for burnout. Can individual workers determine if they're experiencing burnout or is this something that really has to be measured objectively by the employer or an outside consultant, for example? You know, quite honestly, I have never heard people say, I don't know what burnout is. Can I take a test? It's like this medical diagnosis again, which is really wrong. You know, it's a stress response. And people usually, if they think about their own experience, no, am I exhausted in feeling stress?
你只是觉得不对劲或在某种程度上是错误的事情。所以就是这六个领域：工作量、控制权、奖励、社区、公平和价值观，这是我们目前所知的导致倦怠风险的六大驱动因素。个人员工能确定自己是否正在经历倦怠吗？还是这真的必须由雇主或外部顾问等客观衡量？你知道，老实说，我从来没听过人们说：“我不知道什么是倦怠。我能参加测试吗？”这就像那个医学诊断一样，这真的很不对。你知道，这是一种压力反应。如果人们思考自己的经历，通常会知道：我是否感到疲惫和压力？
Am I beginning to get really sour on the job and really hate it and don't want to go there and, you know, dislike it, et cetera, but I'm stuck? and how do I feel about how well I'm doing on the job? I don't think it's a mystery in this way. The measure that I developed is a research measure. It's not a diagnostic tool. You develop it so that you're sort of assessing how often do people, how frequently are they experiencing these three aspects of burnout?
我是否开始对工作感到非常厌恶，真的很讨厌它，不想去那里，你知道，不喜欢它等等，但我被困住了？我对自己在工作中的表现感觉如何？我不认为这有什么神秘的。我开发的量表是一种研究工具。它不是诊断工具。你开发它是为了评估人们多久，他们经历这三种倦怠方面的频率是多少？
And what does that correlate with? Or how do we discover other things about causes of burnout? effects of burnout, you know, the kinds of occupations that pose higher risks. So it's a research tool, but that doesn't necessarily say that you can only know it if you take a test. And it should, you know, it shouldn't be used for diagnostic purposes. It should not be used ethically against people's will. And I mean, I've seen organizations where they'll post names on the wall or they'll tap people on the shoulder. It's not confidential or anonymous and saying, oh, I think maybe you're burned out.
它与什么相关？或者我们如何发现关于倦怠原因的其他事情？倦怠的影响，你知道，风险较高的职业类型。所以它是一个研究工具，但这并不一定意味着你只有通过测试才能知道。而且它，你知道，它不应该用于诊断目的。它不应该在违背人们意愿的情况下被不道德地使用。我的意思是，我见过一些组织，他们会把名字贴在墙上，或者拍拍人们的肩膀。这不是保密或匿名的，而是说，哦，我想你可能倦怠了。
You've got a problem. You better go see a therapist. You know, this is just, you know, this is not the way to go. To assess burnout and find out, you know, do we have a problem here? You're looking at the aggregate. You know, where is it showing up? You know, how many, you know, what percentage of your workforce is like that? But it's not to go after the individuals and essentially figure out how to fix them or fire
你有问题。你最好去看治疗师。你知道，这只是，你知道，这不是解决之道。要评估倦怠并找出，你知道，我们这里是否有问题？你要看的是总体情况。你知道，它出现在哪里？你知道，有多少，你知道，你的员工中有多少比例是这样的？但这不是为了针对个人，本质上是为了找出如何修复他们或解雇
them. So there's some real confusion, I think, around some of this. The other thing is that there's more to people's experience than burnout or not. We've identified in research at least five different profiles, ranging from engagement on the more positive end to burnout on the more negative. And three others in the middle, where people are showing maybe one of the burnout components, but not the full three, the high frequency. response to chronic job stresses. So there's a lot more to it than just that. But I think people are concerned about what do you do and how do you handle it. And one of the problems there, I think the challenges is that people tend to focus on what's wrong with the person and then how do we
他们。所以我认为围绕这些问题存在一些真正的困惑。另一件事是，人们的经历不仅仅是倦怠与否。我们在研究中确定了至少五种不同的概况，从积极端的参与到消极端的倦怠。中间还有三种，人们可能表现出倦怠的一个组成部分，但不是全部三个，即对慢性工作压力源的高频反应。所以这不仅仅是那样。但我认为人们关心的是该怎么做以及如何处理它。我认为其中的一个问题，挑战在于人们倾向于关注个人出了什么问题，然后我们如何
fix them or help them cope or whatever. Rather than looking at the other part of that mismatch, which is the job conditions and the workplace. And that has to be fixed or changed or improved or whatever. It's not just focusing on, you know, who are the people who just can't handle this. What are some of the best practices for a workplace where management thinks that employees are experiencing burnout? What do they do? Do they survey employees? You talked about collecting data in the aggregate, but do they also meet with individuals?
修复他们或帮助他们应对等等。而不是关注那种不匹配的另一部分，即工作条件和职场。那必须被修复、改变或改善。不仅仅是关注，你知道，谁是那些无法处理这些的人。对于管理层认为员工正在经历倦怠的职场，有哪些最佳实践？他们该怎么做？他们调查员工吗？你谈到了收集总体数据，但他们也与个人会面吗？
I mean, what should a company do if they think that their employees are burning out? Well, basically, burnout works or, you know, is a signal that things are not going well in the workplace. And it's not just about what's wrong with the people and how do I work with them, but to work with those employees on how could the workplace be made better? How could we improve the situation that they're facing? And so I think it needs a different kind of a dialogue that really focuses on, you know, where might there be some of these chronic job stressors, the pebbles in your shoe, you know, that you're experiencing all the time?
我的意思是，如果公司认为他们的员工正在倦怠，他们应该怎么做？嗯，基本上，倦怠工作，或者，你知道，是一个职场进展不顺利的信号。这不仅仅是关于人们出了什么问题以及我如何与他们合作，而是要与这些员工合作，探讨如何让职场变得更好？我们如何改善他们所面临的情况？所以我认为这需要一种不同类型的对话，真正关注，你知道，这些慢性工作压力源可能在哪里，你一直经历的“鞋里的鹅卵石”，你知道吗？
And using those six areas of mismatch as a guide, where could we begin to change the way we're doing things in terms of the control or the workload or the recognition or the community or something like that. And so it has to be more of a collaborative process, I think, to sort of focus on, you know, what may be the problem areas and how can we go about, you know, making positive improvements. I don't think it needs to have a survey, but there's another point that I think I would make here. and that is that even though there's a lot of discussion about burnout, it's still perceived and treated in a stigmatized way. So trying to find out who has burnout and how much burnout
并利用那六个不匹配领域作为指导，我们可以在控制权、工作量、认可度、社区或其他方面改变我们做事的方式。所以我认为这必须是一个更具协作性的过程，重点关注，你知道，问题领域可能是什么，以及我们如何着手，你知道，做出积极的改进。我不认为一定要进行调查，但我认为这里还有一点我要指出。那就是，尽管关于倦怠的讨论很多，但它仍然被以一种污名化的方式看待和对待。所以试图找出谁有倦怠，倦怠程度如何，
and how much of a problem is burnout. People are often unwilling to answer that, you know, truly, you know, honestly in that if they think there's going to be a downside on that, like that tap on the shoulder saying, what's wrong with you? there see a therapist. Because it is that kind of stigma and there could be negative consequences of it. So taking a focus not on do we have to have people self-identifies burned out before we do anything to improve the workplace?
以及倦怠是一个多大的问题。人们通常不愿意回答，你知道，真正地，你知道，诚实地，如果他们认为这会有负面影响，比如那个拍拍肩膀说“你怎么了？”的人。去看治疗师。因为这是一种污名，而且可能会有负面后果。所以不要专注于在做任何改善职场的事情之前，我们是否必须让人们自我识别为倦怠？
No, you can start improving it. And if there's anything we've learned from the COVID pandemic is that the workplace can be done differently. We've had to do it all here. And some things have worked well. Other things have not. but it can be different. And so let's really think out of the box and try and figure out how do we make a better,
不，你可以开始改善它。如果说我们从新冠疫情中学到了什么，那就是职场可以以不同的方式运作。我们在这里不得不这样做。有些事情运作良好。其他事情则不然。但它可以是不同的。所以让我们真正跳出框框思考，试着找出我们如何创造一个更好、
healthier environment in which people can kind of thrive rather than get beaten down. And that does not require any sort of sign of burnout per se, you know, before you do that. But burnout really tells you more about what's going on in the workplace and what's going on in the individual. There have been a lot of surveys in the past year and a half that found parents, of young children have been extraordinarily stressed, trying to balance their work and child care. Do outside stressors like that contribute to occupational burnout? I think for some people, they argue that there is such a thing as parental burnout and, you know, other kinds of burnout.
更健康的环境，让人们能够茁壮成长，而不是被压垮。在你这样做之前，这不需要任何倦怠的迹象。但倦怠确实能让你更多地了解职场中正在发生的事情，而不是个人身上正在发生的事情。在过去的一年半里，有很多调查发现，有年幼子女的父母压力极大，试图平衡工作和育儿。像这样的外部压力源会导致职业倦怠吗？我认为对于一些人来说，他们认为存在所谓的“父母倦怠”等等。
They're using the same kind of stress analogy there. But, yes, certainly to the extent that you have other things going on in your life, that make it more difficult to do the job well and to be in good shape and your own health and well-being and being able to take care of your family and all the rest of that. That can certainly add to the whole burden. There's no question. So that, you know, that kind of mismatch, you know, between the workload and the rest of your life can be huge as we saw.
他们在这里使用了同样的压力类比。但是，是的，当然，如果你生活中还有其他事情发生，让你更难做好工作，保持良好的状态，照顾好自己的健康和福祉，照顾好你的家庭，以及所有其他事情。这当然会增加整体负担。毫无疑问。所以，你知道，工作量和你生活其他部分之间的那种不匹配，正如我们所见，可能是巨大的。
It also can, there also can be positive things. that it happened with, you know, the working from a home thing. For some people, don't have to commute the way they used to do that. Or maybe they have access to other resources or they can do their work better or some of it on different time frame. So I think there's a lot to, we still need to learn about different possibilities for different kinds of people and different kinds of occupations. So you've written about the fact that people tend to think of burnout as an individual problem and something. it's something that needs to be addressed by the person who's experiencing it, but it's actually the workplace problem.
它也可能，也可能有一些积极的事情。居家办公发生的事情。对于一些人来说，不必像以前那样通勤。或者也许他们可以获得其他资源，或者他们可以更好地完成工作，或者在不同的时间框架内完成部分工作。所以我认为还有很多，我们仍然需要了解不同类型的人和不同类型的职业的不同可能性。所以你写过关于人们倾向于将倦怠视为个人问题，并且认为这是需要经历它的人解决的事情，但实际上它是职场问题。
It needs to be solved at the mega level. Can you talk about that a little bit? Yeah. I mean, this is what I am talking about in terms of the relationship between the job and the person, that using an either-or thing, is it the job, is it the person? When the answer really is, it's both. and you need to really think about what is happening in terms of those chronic job stressors that are there most of the time, all of the time, that are just wearing people down
它需要在宏观层面解决。你能谈谈那个吗？是的。我的意思是，这就是我所说的关于工作与人之间的关系，使用“非此即彼”的思维，是工作的问题，还是人的问题？当答案实际上是，两者都是。你需要真正思考在慢性工作压力源方面正在发生什么，这些压力源大部分时间、所有时间都在那里，只是在消耗人们，
and how do we make changes there as well as helping people to relax and cope and, you know, and all that kind of thing. But a lot of those chronic job stressors that people are responding to or trying to deal with are ones over which they have no control and can't be changed or, you know, it shakes how they're able to live their life and do their day or, you know, night hours or whatever ship they're working. And so there's always a bigger, better approach to this. And it's not just by individual jobs. It's also about how do we make assignments, how do we decide how to get X done as opposed to
以及我们如何在那里做出改变，同时帮助人们放松和应对，你知道，以及所有这类事情。但人们正在回应或试图处理的许多慢性工作压力源，是他们无法控制的，无法改变的，或者，你知道，它动摇了他们过生活的方式，以及他们白天或，你知道，夜间工作的时间，或者他们工作的任何轮班。所以总有一个更大、更好的方法来解决这个问题。这不仅仅是关于个人工作。这也是关于我们如何分配任务，我们如何决定如何完成 X 而不是
why? If we're adding more to people's plates, you know, in terms of the work they have to do, what are we going to subtract? What is, you know, no longer as necessary? To simply say, sorry, we just have to do more with less, which is what we're hearing a lot, it's just a kind of an overload phenomenon that is bound to cause more stress for more people with all those negative consequences. And so a real solution is not simply to say, if you can't take the heat, get out of the kitchen, it's like, okay, we'll help you cope and do better in this kind of environment, but we're also going to work on the kitchen to make it a better place to do that kind of work. We have to look at both. I mean, burnout in that sense is sort of like the canary in the coal mine.
为什么？如果我们给人们增加了更多的工作量，你知道，就他们必须做的工作而言，我们要减去什么？什么是，你知道，不再那么必要的？简单地说，“抱歉，我们必须用更少的人做更多的事”，这是我们经常听到的，这只是一种过载现象，必然会导致更多的人承受更大的压力，并带来所有那些负面后果。所以真正的解决方案不仅仅是说，“如果你受不了热，就离开厨房”，而是说，“好吧，我们会帮助你在这种环境中应对并做得更好，但我们也会致力于改善厨房，使其成为做那种工作的更好地方。”我们必须两者兼顾。我的意思是，从这个意义上说，倦怠就像煤矿里的金丝雀。
the canary goes down the canary is having problems operating in the coal mine it's not that something is wrong with the canary that it's not tough enough uh tough full bird it's that it's toxic fumes and it's a signal that something needs to be fixed before everybody else goes into the mine so burn that's for me burnout is really um more of that kind of signal that's sort of saying it's it's becoming too difficult too much with too many negative consequences for not only the workers but but but the people they deal with, their family life, and so forth. And we have to address both. A recent Washington Post story talked about some of the solutions that companies are trying to implement to combat burnout, and some of them are offering an extra week of vacation time. Others are shutting down for a week, so everyone has to take time off. Some employers are offering flexible schedules,
金丝雀倒下了，金丝雀在煤矿里运作出现了问题，并不是金丝雀本身出了什么问题，它不是一只不够强壮的鸟，而是因为有毒气体，这是一个信号，在其他人进入矿井之前，有些事情需要修复。所以对我来说，倦怠确实是，嗯，更多的是那种信号，它在说，它变得太困难了，太多了，不仅对工人，而且对他们打交道的人、他们的家庭生活等等，都带来了太多的负面后果。我们必须两者兼顾。《华盛顿邮报》最近的一篇报道谈到了一些公司试图实施的对抗倦怠的解决方案，其中一些公司提供额外一周的假期。另一些公司则关闭一周，所以每个人都必须休假。一些雇主提供灵活的时间表，
and some are experimenting with a four-day work week. are these good ideas, do they effectively combat burnout, or is there something kind of counterintuitive about trying to solve burnout by telling people to get away from the workplace? You hit it right on the head. I mean, it's a strange thing, but often, you know, the best way to cope with, you know, work stress is not to work. And that makes the question, what's wrong with the work that, you know, to deal with it, you have to cut out, get away, take time off, take a vacation, you know, do fewer hours,
还有一些正在试验四天工作制。这些是好主意吗？它们能有效地对抗倦怠吗？还是说，试图通过告诉人们远离职场来解决倦怠，这有点反直觉？你一针见血。我的意思是，这是一件奇怪的事情，但通常，你知道，应对工作压力的最好方法是不工作。这就引出了一个问题，工作出了什么问题，以至于，你知道，为了处理它，你必须切断、离开、休假、休假、减少工作时间，
all that kind of thing. So there's a distinction I think that's important to make here between coping and prevention. Coping by getting away in some way, fewer hours, take a vacation, a week off from work or something like that, take a vacation, is coping with stressors, but it's leaving your job as it is. And if it is what it is, then when you go back, those stressors are still going to be there
所有这类事情。所以我认为在这里区分“应对”和“预防”很重要。通过某种方式离开来应对，减少工作时间，休假，从工作中休息一周或类似的事情，休假，是在应对压力源，但它让你的工作保持原样。如果它就是这样，那么当你回去时，那些压力源仍然会存在，
and it's still going to be the problems that we're, you know, leading to the burnout in the first place. So to prevent to actually change the likelihood that, you know, burnout will occur is you want to somehow begin to make changes in the conditions that are causing the problem of burnout.
而且它仍然会是导致倦怠的问题。所以要预防，要真正改变倦怠发生的可能性，你想要以某种方式开始改变导致倦怠问题的条件。
So those chronic job stressors, if you just leave them in place it's not making a difference and we've seen in other research on you know the value of vacations and getting away and so forth there's always a kind of an initial good thing you feel better you come back saying oh yeah now I'm ready to go to work and pretty soon it's all back to where it was and it's not good so you know it's a coping strategy but it's not really dealing with the problem which is what are the chronic job stressors that are
所以那些慢性工作压力源，如果你只是把它们留在原地，那并没有什么区别，我们在关于假期和离开等等的价值的其他研究中也看到过，总有一种最初的好处，你感觉更好，你回来时说，“哦，是的，现在我准备好去工作了”，很快一切又回到了原点，这并不好。所以你知道，这是一种应对策略，但它并没有真正解决问题，即什么是慢性工作压力源，
causing the difficulties for everybody. What about workplace wellness programs, things like offering yoga or meditation or paying for employees gym memberships? And I know Amazon recently got some criticism for installing a Zen booth meditation kiosk in its warehouses without really doing anything else to change the working conditions. But do any of these wellness programs address burnout? out? No, not really. I mean, again, they are all pretty much coping strategies. The job is what it is. You're still in the warehouse, doing whatever, but we have this thing over here, and maybe that will help you feel better if you use it and, you know, take some time off and all of that kind of thing. So again, it's a
给每个人造成困难。那么职场健康计划呢，比如提供瑜伽或冥想，或者支付员工的健身房会员费？我知道亚马逊最近因为在仓库里安装了“禅定亭”冥想亭而受到了一些批评，却没有做任何其他事情来改变工作条件。但这些健康计划中有任何一个能解决倦怠吗？不，并没有。我的意思是，同样，它们几乎都是应对策略。工作就是那样。你仍然在仓库里，做着任何事情，但我们这里有这个东西，也许如果你使用它，你知道，休息一下，所有这些事情，那会帮助你感觉更好。所以同样，这是一个
coping strategy, but it's leaving the job conditions as they are. So the other thing about wellness strategies, I think a lot of them can have a positive effect. There's a huge self-care industry out there with all kinds of ideas and possibilities for helping people to cope and be more healthy and, you know, all that kind of thing. But, you know, tell people to be more healthy and relax and be sure you get your eight hours of sleep a night and so forth when you're an overload and you're taking work home and it's disrupting. in your family life and your sleep, et cetera, you know, that's not going to help. You have to change those of the job conditions.
应对策略，但它让工作条件保持原样。所以关于健康策略的另一件事是，我认为它们中的许多可以产生积极的影响。外面有一个巨大的自我保健行业，有各种各样的想法和可能性来帮助人们应对并变得更健康，你知道，所有这类事情。但是，你知道，当你在超负荷工作，把工作带回家，并且它正在破坏你的家庭生活和睡眠等等时，告诉人们要更健康、放松并确保你每晚睡够八小时等等，你知道，那不会有帮助。你必须改变那些工作条件。
So the other issue about wellness strategies that I think I just want to point out is that in many cases, the ideas are good, but they sometimes are badly implemented. So you're telling people, you must do X, but not on company time or, you know, some sort of thing like that. The other part of not doing it well implementing it is that I'm surprised how often the employees are never asked if this Zen booth would be a good thing. If they could have a choice of what would happen that would make life better, what would be the things that would really like to see. And so much of this stuff essentially gets implemented, top down, without getting input from bottom side, whatever, as to
所以我认为我只想指出的关于健康策略的另一个问题是，在许多情况下，想法是好的，但它们有时实施得很糟糕。所以你告诉人们，你必须做 X，但不能在公司时间，或者，你知道，某种类似的事情。没有做好实施的另一部分是，我很惊讶员工们从未被问及这个禅定亭是否是一件好事。如果他们可以选择什么会让生活变得更好，他们真正想看到的是什么。所以很多这些东西本质上是自上而下实施的，没有得到自下而上的投入，至于
what would really make a difference. And so I've seen all kinds of wellness things that don't get much uptake. I mean, people don't do them that much because it's really not the kind of thing that is helpful to that. It doesn't fit well within the kind of job they're doing and so forth. And, you know, you really need to check, you know, of all the many solutions that might be out there that will help people and make them feel better about doing the job, you to check first whether this is something they really want.
什么才是真正能带来改变的。所以我见过各种各样的健康项目，并没有得到太多的参与。我的意思是，人们并没有做那么多，因为这真的不是那种有帮助的事情。它不太适合他们正在做的工作类型等等。而且，你知道，你真的需要检查，你知道，在可能存在的所有许多解决方案中，哪些会帮助人们并让他们对工作感觉更好，你首先要检查这是否是他们真正想要的。
I have seen things that are wonderful, you know, volleyball courts on the roof for the building, un-used because nobody wants to, you know, and can't get off work to go and do that. And you need a team and all this kind of thing. So it's just not well thought out. And so we see a lot of things where the intention is good, but the implementation is not.
我见过很棒的东西，你知道，大楼屋顶上的排球场，闲置着，因为没人想，你知道，也没法下班去打球。而且你需要一个团队和所有这类事情。所以这只是没有经过深思熟虑。所以我们看到很多事情，意图是好的，但实施却不是。
And it rubs people the wrong way. They're being treated in a very paternalistic way as though you don't know anything better. We're doing something good for you. So, you know, go do it. And often it's, and by the way, you're going to lose some weight, okay? And, you know, and maybe stop smoking and all that kind of thing. And, you know, so they're being talked down to. And I think that somehow also doesn't help them realize that maybe some of what's being offered could actually be useful.
而且它让人们感到不舒服。他们被以一种非常家长式的方式对待，好像你什么都不知道。我们正在为你做一些好事。所以，你知道，去吧。而且通常是，顺便说一句，你会减掉一些体重，好吗？而且，你知道，也许戒烟和所有这类事情。而且，你知道，所以他们被居高临下地对待。而且我认为这在某种程度上也没有帮助他们意识到，也许所提供的一些东西实际上可能是有用的。
But there's often a mismatch there of attention. Oh, here's a good, healthy thing. And can people actually use it? And it doesn't make a difference. Is it worth the money? Is it worth the investment? Any good return on it? Not so much.
但那里通常存在注意力的不匹配。哦，这是一个好的、健康的东西。人们真的能使用它吗？而且它并没有带来什么改变。它值得花钱吗？它值得投资吗？它有好的回报吗？没那么多。
Well, this has been really interesting, Dr. Masluck. I really appreciate your joining us today. And I hope our listeners have gained a greater understanding of what burnout is and isn't and how to deal with it. Thank you. Thank you so much. I really appreciate the opportunity that eight. gave me to talk about this. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.
好吧，这真的很有趣，马斯拉赫博士。我非常感谢您今天加入我们。我希望我们的听众对什么是倦怠、什么不是倦怠以及如何处理它有了更深入的了解。谢谢。非常感谢。我非常感谢这个机会，让我谈论这个话题。你可以在 www. 找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please, if there's an opportunity, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman, Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening.
speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方。请，如果有机会，给我们留下评论。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，在 apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作，我们的声音编辑是 Chris Kondayan。感谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。